I think we are sleepwalking our way into
World War III sleepwalking our way into
World War II with one foolish decision
after another here's a generic intro to
a clip we wanted to show you this to me
is the most dangerous part of it is in
theory it should be easy to avoid World
War II because no one wants it but we
have an Administration in Washington
that seems to be blundering around that
is constantly overplaying its F and it
doesn't seem to be using diplomacy
whatsoever I I think we are sleepwalking
our way into World War II sleepwalking
our way into world three with one
foolish decision after another as
youline David and really people should
be deeply self-reflective if they if
their predictions have not come true
they should consider whether perhaps
their other predictions might not come
true either I mean what is the track
record here it's not good you know it's
funny in in the investing world you know
the VC World in which you know we
operate track record is all important
you know we when you want to assess
whether an investor is good at their job
or not the first you look at is track
record but there seems to be no concept
of a track record yes it's astonishing
and and the stakes are so much higher I
mean we're talking about many lives and
Devastation and you know I just want to
keep reiterating this point
civilizational risk must be Paramount
because if civilization goes away it's
all over for
everyone and we you know it worries me
that the veterans of World War II are
almost all dead they so those who
remember the of a World War are no no
longer who has the visceral knowledge of
of what a world war is really like when
when people have grown up cuddled and
comfort they have no concept of
War